There's some fucking,
you go into that deep country music.
What were you just telling me about
country music that some giant country rap.
What is the song? It's called Old
Town road. Old Town road. Old Town.
Like one of the biggest
songs out of it's at the,
it's number one on the regular church
in the country. Took charge, right?
You put it together, little nausea x, is
that right? Everyone's a little licks.
Little Nas. What? A little nausea
but so he was on the country charge.
They took him off because
like this isn't country man,
but then he linked up with Miley Cyrus's
dad. What's his name? Billy Ray. Cyrus.
Billy Ray Cyrus.
How dare you.
I think what also has to do with this
is he used at whether he did it or not,
I don't know,
but he used the video game,
red dead redemption and some of the
cool graphics and then made a rap song.
Country rap song. It's called called
country trap is what they're calling it.
That's why it's a different
thing, but it's got, it's got,
it's catchy and it's based around
this kind of stuff. It got it got hot,
it caught, they're
caught. The wave country,
like the djs on all the stations were
like just ripping it off of youtube and
playing it. That's why it made it on the
billboard. And then build board is like,
no, this isn't a country song. Take
it off. And then because that almost,
it's like Streisand effect.
It got bigger. So they um,
they who, who, who took it off
billboard did, why did they take it off?
Because it doesn't,
and there third a description was that
it doesn't meet the qualifications to
meet country with Billy Ray.
Cyrus jumped on board and then there's
video of him and Billy Ray Cyrus in the
studio. No, it's so interesting
when you're looking at the
footage of it. How cool.
That fucking game. This is just a game.
This is, that's a huge game, right? Yeah.
Red Redemption two but what a great idea
to wrap over real smart Dempson that's
a genius idea.
I think that game is played in here.
Jamie and I would play that game.
Yeah. You guys beat the Shit on me.
Whatever game we played last
than that was quick as, fuck.
You don't want to fuck with that game.
Do we just talk a little about us?
Tom Papa walked in, Jeff and
I were in battle into the
death. Tom Papa don't play.
You know, he was just watching us
going, what the fuck are you doing?
What are you doing? What are you
doing? Tom Pop is so funny, man.
He just wants everything to be old school.
He's still wants to go to the,
to the paper vendor and get a newspaper
and bake his own bread. I take that.
What does this Manson, what does
that, they've made a remix stuff,
but now with Billy Ray, it's just like
a real video. Now they've got money.
They know. Oh Wow. I'm not
feeling the real video too.
I liked the way you just do dances
with a cowboy hat on. No, but he's low.
He's become a star because of this.
It's getting played. All the festivals,
all the last couple of weeks.
The crowds are loving it.
Why didn't he open up at Coachella? It
was already booked. It's more along.
It's just happened so quick. You could
sneak them in. Billy Ray Cyrus slip bit,
your mind ready to get his whistle wet at
Coachella might've played it, I'm sure.
But like I saw that little like the
Yodel kid was singing this song.
Like he's even taught
on all kinds of shit.
Do you know who Billy Ray Cyrus is
until you know his big hit? Oh yeah.
Don't keep breaking my heart. Keep her
in a weird, his daughter's way bigger.
Um, he was really huge for a
brief moment in time. But yeah,
he was never like what
she is. She, she, she,
she can sound to fuck. And she was
on that crazy. Disney hit forever.
Hannah, my Hannah Montana
forever, which made no sense.
I put a wig on and nobody knows
this video together. This strange.
That's so ridiculous. Like
Batman, there is glorious locks.
God looks like Joe's brother.
Yeah.
So how from everybody was doing the
Achy breaky heart back then, 53 million.
I bet that must have fucking freaked
him out, man. Take his famous,
he was back then for that brief moment
in time to sweared are now almost could
be famous like back then you could get
away with things and now it's a nightmare.